we got this 84 inch roller and 102 litre  bottles of soda let's see what happens  so we went to Costco to get all these we  pretty much emptied out their entire  coke collection just for you guys don't  feel bad for the wasted soda you  shouldn't be drinking that stuff anyway  kids okay this is how awesome  what I want to see is just pure  explosion we got jared here shaking up  bottles that's the next move we got them  all laid out we're gonna start shaking  them and get crazy let's do this  [Music]  Oh  oh that is awesome oh look at the chaos  that's beautiful just look look at the  carnage we got bottles all the way over  there in the corner bottle caps were  flying off it sounded like fireworks for  a second it was awesome that was so much  fun  why is exploding things so much fun I  don't know I'm not searching for a  deeper answer I just want to see more  you should explode some more stuff right  [Music]